what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Sundance
2024 I'm so excited to be sitting with
the team behind my most anticipated film
of the festival Love Lies bleeding I
cannot wait to see the movie tonight
you're going to love
it ever since St mod I've been eagerly
awaiting your next film and tonight's
the night before we get into our
conversation I have to give a special
shout out to our wonderful sponsor filo
filo is wonderful because they let us be
here at Sundance supporting independent
film making they are also a
groundbreaking company that puts the
power to Greenlight movies in the hands
of the creators and the fans so if you'd
like to learn a little more about filo
check out their website
film. okay Rose you're first up on my
list here I've got two questions about
making this your second feature one what
was it about the story that Drew you to
it but also what did you think you would
gain from making this movie Next as a
director Hony a
craft I think going into it I just knew
that I wanted to you know try something
different and take some risks and
challenge myself I knew wanted to make
something fun and kind of bombastic and
pulpy I didn't have a clear view of the
story yet I knew I wanted to co-write as
well CU like doing M love making the
film writing by yourself is quite
isolating and stressful so I thought
again try something different so I
teamed up with rilsa who's the writer
director as well um been friends for
years
and we like Weedle each other's stuff so
I basically came to her with this sort
of embryonic version of the idea um and
then we just locked ourselves in a room
for a few months and just kind of
brainstormed the whole thing and came up
with these characters and just tried to
I don't know try out different things
and see where the story led us and go
with whatever felt the most fun and
exciting and surprising tried to make
each other laugh probably no surprise my
uh next question is another complicated
two-parter because I'm always fascinated
by the experience of going from a
successful first feature to getting your
second off the ground because I feel
like there can be a misconception that
it's easy so what is a misconception
about what it takes to get your second
feature a green light but then I also
want the opposite something about St mod
that did make this process easy for
you I
guess I I tried just to sort of not stop
and think about it too much I suppose I
think it was just kind of there's such
an exciting momentum of having got to a
point where you've actually made a film
because for so long before that it's
just kind like oh am I going to get to
make one um so I just tried to sort of
like follow that momentum I guess I mean
I was really fortunate that I got to
team up with a24 and film 4 supported
supported us again um to develop the
script um and everyone took a bit of a
risk
so yeah I don't know just kind of went
with it if you're not taking a risk is
it worth it no exactly I think so at
least um Kristen and Katie I've got yet
another two-parter for the two of you to
get into your characters here when you
first signed on to the movie what
quality of your characters were you most
looking forward to playing but then I
also want to know what quality you
discovered along the way as you started
to work
together
sure um when Rose described the film to
me she was like everyone's always
telling me to write about like or or at
least that we're all talking about women
telling stories about strong
women and so her leaning I thought that
that intro cuz it was I met her before I
read the script was so funny it felt
like kind of like hot and petulant and I
was like what is this going to be just
like you know really strong women and
then we got a very strong woman to be in
this movie opposite my very weak woman
and uh I don't know like to get back to
your exact question
I I really like these people a lot but
they're like morally defunct and
completely like you know willing to
justify any bad behavior because of love
and that feels like something that's
easy to sort of be like yeah that's a
good idea but really we just humans just
tell themselves the story that they need
to hear in order to get through and like
I guess I loved lose so much and cuz
she's funny and she's kind of like a
good guy she's kind of like an affable
dude but ultimately I was like oh no we
can all just be pretty monstrous because
we're all just humans and um I don't
know has anyone seen Oppenheimer
you know what I mean it's like yeah
we're all uh
so it was surprising to me like having
to sort of like really love Lou and
protect her the whole time and then we
got to the end of the movie I was like
or really more when I saw the movie I
was like
oh no bad guy but not bad let's not be
so binary you know we're all we've all
goded we're we contain multitudes you
know I feel like that's the perfect
combo lose yourself in it in the moment
but then be able to still experience the
movie even though you made it when you
get to watch it as an outsider looking
in that's cool everyone's just tripping
to the finish line and like smashing
their faces into each other at least it
gets to be kind of hot you know what I
mean I um I I think Jackie was just this
really kind of sweet naive dreamer and I
loved that about her but also had a bit
of ferocity and um and maybe a bit of
tragedy to her and I think what was
really cool when you put her and Lou
together is L very much like the only
support I think she's ever had and very
like grounded and also there's like a
really cool masculine feminine just
position where you've got me like the a
bodybuilder or whatever and I'm all you
know putting makeup on and doing my hair
and being all cutesy whatever I took
care of you yeah you took care of me
thank you so much um and and yeah Lou
yeah Lou took care of me and I was like
yeah it was so sweet I one more one more
question for the a little flipflop power
Dynamic nothing hotter than
that good some good teas is there
another question for for both of you and
I I love asking this question in general
but in particular when it seems like I
don't know two characters in their
connection together do serve as the
Beating Heart of the film which is the
impression the Press notes gave me at
least can you each tell me something
about the other that you appreciated as
a scene partner and helped you access
something in your character that you
might not have been able to reach
without
them I think I mean one of the things
was uh for me was like generally I
didn't have a lot of boundaries and I
think Kristen was like just really
willing to to do the things that needed
to be done and we had a scene where you
had like a lighter and like that lighter
is near me on my skin um you know it's
it's like it's we're we're living as
true to the moment as we can and and
we're we're able to actually feel what's
happening in the moment which is really
nice cuz sometimes I feel like people
will be really timid and just kind of be
like oh I'll just I'll hold it you know
I wasn't going to fake it for you we 8
we'll just put it in later and post you
know whatever it's like yeah it's just
like do we have a bigger lighter more
more fire is there a torch around here
he very safe yeah um
it I feel like
uh lose a tough guy and the coolest the
the coolest feeling is
being thrown over her shoulder and like
a little bit
flun um yeah like I don't know Katie and
I we did we did this like initial
audition and this movie was it was we
were both both just very much plunged
off a cliff into a dark weird deep water
and uh yeah like there was never a point
where we were like pushing each other
under you know what I mean it was just
sort of like I don't know it was hard it
was so
hard it was really fun though and that
was definitely because of this like
weird alchemical thing that was going on
between the three of us that's awesome
all right Jen I'm going to come your way
kind of a scene partnering question as
well because in our press notes it did
emphasize that you and Kristen have
known each other for a while and you're
playing sisters in the movie but you've
never worked together right not directly
at least we were in the same film you're
in the same F that's working together
right I mean I've been obsessed with
Jenna loone since I've been watching
movies and so like when I got to work
with her went into the wild I was
like and then met more like impress
engagements on that film you know it was
like yeah separate separate worlds what
was your what was your first movie of
hers that got you obsessed with her as
an
actor well I mean like all the little
guy stuff is the cutest thing ever but
like dangerous lives in the Altar Boys
is so
cute genuinely like everything yeah
Jenna back to you what is something
about having that long- lasting
connection that you found influencing
the fact that you were playing sisters
in this movie I mean I think from the
very first time that we met and even
circled I felt a very like oddly like
maternal like older something sister
like we're in the same boat want to like
protect you build you up up like make
sure you're cool um and she just
infinitely was and so I was like oh
that's so amazing like I'm so proud of
you um so yeah it was a very easy you
know bridge to build and sort of there
was a in you know infinite amount of
things we could pull from in the sense
of you know respecting each other and
getting to sort of play off each other
and uh learn to kind of hate each other
also in a way
cuing yeah there's a lot of there's a
lot of uh seed workor of violence in you
know family Dynamics and I think it's
nice to be able to trust someone to be
able to go there in a way that's very
authentic because it can be really scary
I mean I think it's it's the birthplace
of violence right I mean Family Family
Dynamics it's so wild are you able to
tease any of that seed work like can you
can you tease what kind of sparked that
that friction between right now I'm like
you can have it I
love I me more like ideas and backstory
but if you want to do that for it going
to wrestle no when she got mad at me in
stuff because we have a tumultuous
relationship in the
movie it genuinely destroys me I'm like
Jenna don't this you are you is this
okay it was fun though it's it's really
nice to to wrestle greatest part from
sister to Dad Ed I'm going to come to
you next I I love asking this question
when it's a character that seems like
they probably like exude confidence and
authority and that's certainly the
impression I've gotten of Lou Senor from
what I've read about the film so at the
start of the movie what do you think his
greatest strength is but then I also
want to know what you think his greatest
weakness is the thing that makes him
vulnerable in what
unfolds his greatest strength um well
first of all I was really excited to be
asked to play Kristen's father not her
grandfather that was really cool
um his strengths well he's he's an
organizer he knows how to he's a
businessman and he's successful some of
that's illegal but you know he he's on
top of the situation he is a confident
Guy and um he's he doesn't he he's
pretty good at manipulating people to do
what he needs them to do that was kind
of his strength I think I guess his
greatest weakness was is the fact
that he's an
I mean not you don't play you
know I don't think of he doesn't think
of himself that way but he's has not
been the greatest dad his daughter
despises
him um and yet he still loves her and uh
so I guess that's a weakness you know
what can I I don't know and he and you
know he has a fondness for
Beatles which I
think is one of his
strengths tell us more about the Beatles
was could to say it's hard to
describe he just you know he appreciates
them yeah that's nice never thought I'd
be so excited to see lighters and
beetles in the movie but here here we
are all right Dave you're next up on my
list I warn you I'm going to bring up
the rental also uh somebody that I used
to know too but I'm a genre lover so the
rental I watched probably too many times
that's so nice as a director yourself is
there anything you observed Rose doing
as a leader on set and an actor's
director that you kind of back pocketed
and plan to take to your next future
definitely Rose she just sets such a
good vibe on set where she is no matter
how crazy the scenes are it's like she's
so calm and sweet and she never feels
frazzled and she just like I don't know
it's very comforting she just comes up
and gives you these like she doesn't
have to say much she just gives you
these little things and it's just like
ooh that's genius and it just I make a
meal out of
yes uh but really her energy is
something that I responded to a lot
thanks Dave yeah make more movies please
thank you all right Anna so for Daisy
now I I was told that Daisy they were
once in a relationship that has broken
apart but but she's still into her what
what draws her to her but then also what
is that Rift mean for the rest of their
Journey or at least what what can you
tease without spoiling it o yeah is
still into I think is like the
understatement of the century she's I
think kind of pathetically totally
obsessed I got literally one sentence
about your character and I already felt
that in that one sentence yeah um yeah I
mean I you know I imagine that they've
known each other for a long time and
that there aren't a lot of other you
know there's not a ton of maybe on L end
there's not a ton of other options but I
think for Daisy she I think Daisy's so
um you know the movie deals so much with
strength and I think Daisy is someone
who doesn't feel strong at all and Lou
seems like this kind of
steady you know capable presence and is
hot and she loves her I mean I think
it's it's she's pretty um head over
heels and what was the rest of the
question I have a habit of doing this um
how I mean it it could Teeter into
spoiler territory so as it tees
something about that Rift between them
that could influence the overall events
in the film yeah tricky tricky to
I will say is that you know I think so
much of of I what I love about the movie
is that there's this weird balance of of
romance and just completely Sinister
shitty behavior and and that felt so
true that felt so true for for Lou and
Jackie but I really felt like it it
could apply to Daisy as well that she
was willing to do yeah almost kind of in
a really concentrated way she's just
willing to blow it all all up for um who
she loves I just want to say real quick
just hearing everyone talk it's like
everyone's playing a character that's so
outside of themselves in this movie in
such an amazing way and again I go back
to Rose who just kind of like created
this like comfortable environment where
everyone could take such big swings and
everyone is so good in this it's so
unlike what you see up here yeah and it
was like doing an extreme comedy and
like the darkest drama ever but like all
in the same breath never one scene to
the next it was like if it's not
devastating and hilarious we're messing
it up such good teases I can't wait for
tonight Rose I wanted to make sure to
ask you this Kristen had already kind of
brought this up but I have a a specific
quote from our notes where you were you
were saying that the film is somewhat
sending up the idea of the strong female
character and questioning what people
actually mean by that now that the movie
is finished and you've had this
experience how have you redefined to you
what it means to be a strong female
[Music]
character I mean could be that
that to be honest fortunately I mean it
felt it was always like a fairly um
throwaway kind of childish response to
be honest on my part it's really it's
good well but it's like I mean luckily I
think already the the whole sort of
Trope of or concept of a strong female
character already hopefully feels a
little bit P but um I guess you know
it's just a fa Hollow idea and um I
guess if the film sort of about anything
maybe it's sort of you know strength for
strength sake is I don't know there's no
sort of virtuousness in that I don't
know
um yeah it's just Hollow and let's look
at something more interesting and real
through a really heightened weird unreal
story clearly there's many things about
this movie that I'm excited about but
when I read that particular paragraph
I'm like yes this sounds like it's for
me before I have to let you go Kristen I
have one question for you about your
directorial debut cuz I was reading
another piece that that was released
this week and you said that you know you
were you were here promoting movies but
also trying to make that happen and this
is the manifestation table so what will
what will you get for that movie while
you're at Sundance that will allow you
to leave Park City and go make that
movie oh my God LOL I was just like
that's all I'm thinking about right now
it's not like this place and like coming
to the I'm genuinely here for her movie
and for love me um it's just that it's
hard to talk about anything else right
now and people are like what's up how
you how you doing I'm like I'm doing one
thing and it's just trying to get to the
point that we can make the film and
um what a bummer for you to ask me this
question when I'm not allowed to tell
you anything fair enough fair enough
I'll I'll CH I'll change the
manifestation angle and I will just say
like with authority cuz I believe in you
all you are going to have a phenomenal
Premiere tonight I'm sure you're going
to give me another movie that I'm going
to watch over and over and over again so
congratulations on love lives bleeding
thank thank you for having us than for
having us so everybody out there keep an
eye out for the movie and also big
thanks to filo for sponsoring us stay
tuned more from Sundance 2024 for you
very
soon